good morning believe nation today's
message is hustle over to you Wendy
Williams
I wake up every mood in espresso GV go I
i worked for Miss Hughes for about eight
months and I got an a weekend gig in New
York so I would do weekdays at WOL in
Washington and drive up on fridays after
my shift which would end at seven
o'clock and I'd be on all weekend long
over in Queens that's where the radio
station was located and then I would
drive back to DC and I would never even
stopped at my parents house never had
time for friends because everybody was
kind of not understanding my dream and
kind of laughing at me or something or
trying to you know my friends were like
real immature and stupid and wanting to
party and hang out and I'm on a path and
my parents were very you know who do you
want something to eat what is this crazy
thing you're doing called radio I would
sleep in my Subaru they gave me a Subaru
for college graduation and I I would
sleep in my car at every rest stop
between new york and and washington DC
to block out the noise of people tell
you you can't do it right I would
literally be I'd have a blanket an alarm
clock and a quilt and I would take a
bird bath in the bathroom might be woken
up by the man sweeping next to my Subaru
looking at me because I'm like the crazy
you know girl in the and I had a baby
shade without a baby pull the baby shade
down you know and that was my life for
about two months so what do you think I
think it's so important to hustle I
remember a time not too long ago a year
actually when I started my business and
I was hustling I was getting my own
clients I was networking I was doing the
actual work meeting with clients and I
would wake up to go into the office at
five in the morning and I wouldn't get
home till 10 or 11 at night go to bed
and then wake up and do it all over
again every day six or seven days a week
and it was really challenging I felt
that there was no end in sight when one
day my bookkeeper told me you know what
you're doing really well you're doing
great you're in a really good spot right
now and I was able to hire someone
full-time
year after starting my business and the
two of us are now hustling together to
reach that point where we can hire a
third person we're really excited about
that I was having this conversation with
Alex yesterday I feel like I feel like
we're spoiled and we're lazy I feel like
we don't work as hard as our parents say
they're our grandparents did I feel like
the problems that we complain about
aren't really that big of problems
compared to what a lot of people are
going through and we're just not working
hard enough for our dreams you know like
Andrew was hustling waking up at five in
the morning coming home at ten or eleven
at night you know you're hustling there
is a point where you break like you
cannot work anymore you're physically
exhausted but i don't think most people
work anywhere close to that and as a
result you don't get the goals that you
want right like you don't accomplish the
things that you want to accomplish i
think i'm lazy right now compared to
what i could be i think i've heard to
most people I'm hustling my face off but
I think compared to what I could do I'm
still lazy i'm comfortable like i have a
nice condo i have a great wife I have a
son like I have businesses it's amazing
but I'm complacent I could I could do
more I could I could hustle more and I
think I think all you guys could have
some more I think a lot of you guys are
being a little lazy to a little slacker
you gotta hustle a little bit more I'll
see your face off that's my thoughts
so the question today today is can you
tell us about a time when you're
hustling paid off when you're hustling
paid off leave it in the comments below
and we'll join the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso and espresso and
Emma Spencer and an espresso